en cette période de fêtes donald trump
se montre généreux alors que son mandat
prend fin dans un peu plus de trois
semaines
le milliardaire américain use de son
pouvoir présidentiel pour accordé des
grâces à tour de bras
parmi les bénéficiaires son ex
conseiller diplomatique
georges papadopoulos qui avait reconnu
avoir menti au fbi aille dans le cadre
de l' enquête pour une présumée
collusion entre trump et la russie lors
de la campagne de 2016 ancien conseiller
à la sécurité nationale également mêlé à
la faire
michael flynn a déjà été gracié un mois
plus tôt même sort pour son ancien
directeur de campagne polman à fort et
rogers stone un autre ex conseiller plus
choquant encore pour de nombreux
américains
le pardon accordé à quatre ex employé de
la société de sécurité privée blackwater
tous impliqués dans le meurtre de civils
irakiens en 2007
le fondateur de l'entreprise n'est autre
qu'eric prins un fervent partisan du
président le camp démocrate
s'indigne des agissements de trump trump
place ta loyauté au dessus de tout le
reste au dessus de l'état de droit au
dessus de notre démocratie est
certainement au dessus de la justice
je sais que tout ce qu'il fait n'a plus
rien de surprenant mais qu à l'abus de
pouvoir obscène partisans et grossier le
20 janvier n'arrivera jamais assez tôt
ce sont notamment les liens personnels
associant de près ou de loin le
républicain aux personnes grâciées qui
alimentent la polémique outre-atlantique
nombreux considère ces grâces comme un
abus de pouvoir
même s'il n'est pas le premier président
a utilisé cette disposition au dernier
jour de son mandat
bill clinton avait par exemple accorder
le pardon présidentiel à 140 personnes